hello there you're watching Sky News in
just a moment the Press preview a first
look at what's on the front pages as
they arrive but first our top stories a
victim of a Sheffield child grooming
Gang has claimed a serving police
officer who's amongst The Men Who abused
her
opposition parties call for cabinet
office Minister sir Gavin Williamson to
be sat for a third time over claims he
sent abusive text messages to the former
Chief whip
the firebombing of an immigration
processing center in Dover was motivated
by extreme right-wing terrorist ideology
according to the police
foreign
you are watching The Press preview of
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with Ali Mirage and Christina Patterson
there they both are but first let's see
what's on some of the front pages for
you well the Sunday Telegraph tells uh
Chancellor Hunt's latest talks on tax
plans as the politician discusses
halving pension reliefs for millions of
higher rate taxpayers
nurses across the UK vote to launch a
strike over pay is the lead story on
tomorrow's Observer as the biggest
nursing strike in NHS history is set to
take place before Christmas
rishi's extra bank holiday for Charles
is the headline in tomorrow Sunday
Express reporting that the UK will enjoy
an additional holiday to Mark the king's
coronation next year
exposed reads the front of the Sunday
Times its headlined the global hacking
Network that targets VIPs it also
reports on a separate story about Sir
Gavin Williamson with the headline
Williamson's threatening text create
headache for sunac
while tomorrow's Sun reports that three
lines A5 and Tony is at the center of a
match betting probe
the mirror has an exclusive with Orden
Carlson questioning Boy George's
appearance on I'm a celebrity 15 years
after the Culture Club singer Shackled
him to a war and whipped him with a
chain while screaming abuse at him
and the Daily Star Wars Beware of the
Cockroach next to a photo of Matt
Hancock but instead of a report on the
MP's appearance on I'm a celebrity get
me out of here this is a story on how
cockroaches could affect climate change
a reminder that by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages of
tomorrow's newspapers while you watch us
and we are joined tonight by journalist
and author Christina Pattinson and Ali
Mirage of columnist at the article I
welcome to both of you let's start with
the Telegraph and this um new tax being
proposed by the chancellor which will
affect millions of middle class workers
Christina you take us into this story
first of all
yes well this is and obviously trying to
clear up the mess from the disastrous
Liz truss the libertarian experiment
which left us with arguably a 50 billion
black hole and Jeremy Hunt and Rishi
sunak are desperately trying to come up
with solutions that will not be too
unpopular to solve the problem the
trouble is that most of the solutions
are likely to be pretty unpopular I mean
I think they are sensible in in that
they are realizing it can't all be done
by cuts to public services that I not
least I think because to be honest I
think we should see that would very
happily I mean I don't use happily in
the sense of cheerfully but I think he's
a small state politician his instincts
up a small state and he would probably
if he thought he could get away with it
cut Public Services more but he can't in
the current climate because MPS won't
vote for the legislation and there are
certain areas like the NHS but I'm sure
he actually doesn't want to which means
you have to raise some taxes or in this
case reduce some tax relief on pensions
so it means that higher rate
um taxpayers would get less pension
relief possibly halved from up to 40 to
20 which would apparently raise between
8 and 10 billion so who knows if they'll
do that I mean they're having to look at
all kinds of Creative Solutions and I
can't imagine that will go down well
with a lot of Tory party members
um many of them are retired of course
already but those who aren't probably
quite a lot of them are higher rate
taxpayers and certainly Tory MPS will be
hired higher rate taxpayers so um yeah I
can't imagine it's going to go down well
if it goes ahead yes and that we don't
know whether it will in fact go ahead
but but we know that discussions are
ensuing regarding this do you think this
is a good idea Ali
well I'm not sure uh good is probably
the right word uh Julian for this I mean
it's it's an idea that's been floated a
lot of ideas in the run-up to the uh
Autumn statement on November the 17th
will be floated by the government
because uh as Christina said it's got a
50 billion pound black hole to fill now
uh that is going to involve pain I mean
when you've got a situation where we
furloughed loads of people 11.7 million
people we borrowed 400 billion uh to
finance various schemes in covert and
you've got 2.4 trillion of public debt I
always thought it was absolutely fantasy
economics to try and grow your way out
of the problem that taxes are going to
have to go up the thing that Rishi sinek
and Jeremy Hunt are at one on
um is that they realize that this has to
be done in a fair manner therefore you
can't do it on the backs of the poor so
I think they are going to probably have
to skew this to the better off that is
gonna hit them uh probably electorally
uh one could argue uh because a lot of
their supporters will be hit by this but
they have to do the right thing you're
looking at potentially two percent
public sector pay increases across the
thing which is going to go down very
very badly you're also looking
potentially at
capital gains tax and the dividend tax
rate also being reviewed the pensions
triple lock I guess they probably will
leave that because it was a Manifesto
commitment but it's all speculation the
reality is they've got a really
difficult job to do there are no easy
answers here but finally the adults are
back in the room
as you say all speculation we we don't
have a final decision on on any of those
uh policies being put forward for
discussion let us have a look at the
Observer uh and this a very very
worrying Story the biggest nursing
strike in NHS history uh there were
papers reporting is set to take place
before Christmas after Union officials
said that large sways of the country had
voted for industrial action
um very very worrying Christina
well very very worrying for patients
because there's already a waiting list
of about seven million people I'm among
them actually because I broke my knee
and incurred various injuries the other
day and I'm having to wait a long time
for an MRI and might need surgery and
when they don't have to wait a lot
longer so I from that point of view I
probably wouldn't welcome a nurses
strike however I do support them because
they have had um many of them have had
in effect a 20 pay tax since the Tories
took over in 2010 their pay has not kept
um kept up with inflation very far from
it and on top of that the um
circumstances they've had to work in
over the last few years have been really
horrific the stress I've met nurses who
have been utterly traumatized by the
stress they've been through under covert
in fact I met one who who was suffering
from post-traumatic stress disorder and
and the stress continues you know people
think covert is over it isn't and
obviously thank goodness with the
booster um the Autumn booster campaign
having gone relatively well there have
been fewer people going into hospital
with severe covered but there's a back
log of seven million people the strains
are enormous there's not enough funding
so I I really I really sympathize with
nurses and I think if this is what it
takes for them to get more recognition
and better working conditions and a
fairer pay rise then so be it
the government say that the average
basic annual pay for nurses would
increase from about 35 600 pounds to
around thirty seven thousand uh from
March
um and that's a rise of uh just four
percent that said they said March 2022
um this is set to be the first national
strike in the history of the Royal
College of Nursing alley I mean this is
really not what the Prime Minister wants
in his intra is it
no it's not and it's a horrendous
situation that the government's got to
deal with it it's not only nurses it's
also rail workers postal workers rubbish
collectors I mean you could be having
strikes written larger across the public
sector in the run-up to Christmas a
complete nightmare scenario for the
government and I do have some sympathy
with the government here because look
we've got 10 inflation people are
struggling out there it's really really
hard to make a cross and to make a
living a lot of people have seen their
um in the public sector have seen their
real wages falling for the past 10 years
and they've had enough uh and so the
government you know it's got to react
but the reality is that it's got limited
options I mean we've just been talking
about tax increases the only way to do
this is to tax the Richer the rich more
and the problem here is fundamentally
and this has been building up in my view
for a long time now and I speak as a
capitalist I think the capitalist system
is going to fall in on itself unless
there is a more of a move towards
redistribution at the moment yes in the
long term we should be moving towards
supply side reforms and growth but at
the moment people are really struggling
and you've got 50 000 vacancies
in the nursing vacancies in the NHS
right now my own mother was an NHS
doctor for 40 years so I yield to no one
in my admiration for the NHS but it is
really tough out there and then on top
of this you've got in some cases people
waiting for ambulances for over two days
to arrive because there are shortages of
workers all over the place it's a really
really difficult situation Christina
says 7 million waiting list yes and
rising and the other issue is social
care is not being resolved either
because you've got bed blocking in
hospitals and Rishi Cena had to be fair
to him increase the National Insurance
by 1.25 which was then reversed by this
trust now he's probably not going to
March his MPS up the hill again uh to go
and um uh restore it but at least that
was a step in the right direction what
proper Public Public Services they've
got to be funded properly
Christina to the Express and the Home
Secretary the headline there is um on a
mission
major Crackdown on bogus claims as
Tories tackle migrants uh crisis and we
read that she's planning a shake-up of
how Asylum requests are are processed
and those that
are found to be bogus that those people
be kicked out quickly
where does one start with Cruella
bravaman I mean uh she's saying the
system is broken who has been in charge
of the system for the last 12 years does
she think it's labor no it isn't labor
the system is a mess the backlog is
absolutely incredible of the people who
arrived on small boats last year I think
95 have not had their claims processed
so it might be 90 but it's an incredibly
high percentage I mean that's ridiculous
and in the meantime
um she's moaning about putting them up
in hotels well look at the cost to the
taxpayer of having people here for years
at the taxpayers expense it's absolutely
ridiculous they you know and Liz trusses
um refusal to say that Emmanuel macron
was a friend you know when she said the
jury's out and whether he's a friend or
Foe well of course the French were not
going to increase their cooperation at
that point I mean this is a very complex
problem and poverty is at the root of it
because most people in the world
particularly young men from poorer
countries are very high proportion of
them would understandably want to come
to our relatively rich and free country
nobody could blame them for that
um but many of them are using illegal
Roots they are paying Smugglers and then
they are claiming either Asylum or in
the case of many of the young Albanian
men who are disappearing at an enormous
rate they are claiming
um human trafficking or slavery status
now again I don't think one can blame
them for wanting to get a better future
but we can't just let them sit here in
hotels
um and at the taxpayers expense this is
a very complicated issue and Sue Ella
bravaman's posturing and rhetoric and
her really really nasty language talking
about an invasion about people who are
poor and want a better life is deeply
unhelpful I mean actually we have a
massive we have a massive skills
shortage we should be sorting out a Visa
system so people can come and work here
and and and not and trying to sort out
the boats we must leave it there just
because we've got to to go to the break
but but we're going to come back and uh
continue with some other papers and
coming up we've got uh more headaches or
Rishi as the Prime Minister refused last
night to say if he had confidence in sir
Gavin Williamson after an emergency
threatening and exclusive Laden text to
a female colleague stay with us for more
on that
foreign
still with me Christina Patterson
journalist an author and Ali Mirage
communist at the article welcome back to
you both of you let us have a look at
the Sunday Times and this story about
allegations against sir Gavin Williamson
take us uh into this alley
well this is a an exclusive written text
that Gavin Williamson sent the former
Chief whip Wendy Morton uh apparently
something to do with the fact that he
was not invited to the Queen's funeral
and then apparently blamed her for this
so he was very upset about him very
angry now there's a question mark around
whether Rishi sunak should have ever
brought Gavin Williamson back remember
he was very hapless as education
secretary the algorithm and all that
other stuff that he oversaw I mean to be
fair to him it was never an easy task
but certainly he didn't really handle it
perhaps the best way he could have but
the argument is should Richie said I
could have been brought him back as a
Cabinet office Minister uh look that's
an issue for the prime minister to deal
with here I mean certainly you can't be
sending your speed to written text to a
colleague however useless and inept that
colleague is and the fact of the matter
is that Wendy Morton by all accounts was
utterly out of her depth as Chief whip
you could see that in the fracking vote
that took place where no one knew where
they were coming or going people were
being manhandled supposedly really in
tears it was a shambles so whilst I
don't agree with Gavin Williamson will
defend those actions I think Wendy
Morton was utterly useless at Chief whip
but Christina if uh sir Gavin Williamson
was uh sat that this would be the third
time
I mean the fact that we have to call him
sir is so utterly ridiculous I mean that
was again a reward for loyalty which
seems to be the uh the key Criterion
these days for those kinds of honors at
least from government
I mean I I have to say it's it's a
pretty
unsalubrious spectacle to see when these
WhatsApp messages get released into the
public gaze and you see the kind of
language that MPS use to each other but
the colleagues used to each other I have
never I mean I've worked in you know on
Fleet Street or it's not an equivalent
for many years and you know we didn't
use that kind of language to each other
at least not most of the time it seems
to be quite habitual just the the
rudeness and the sense of entitlement
and as you say Jillian he has been
satised before for major major
misbehavior he was I think the worst
education secretary ever so he is
neither competent nor Pleasant I can
only assume he's in the cabinet because
to use that awful cliche he knows where
the bodies are buried and uh sunak Rishi
sunak probably felt he was safer inside
the cabinet than out of it but he can't
stay and nor Consuela bravaman and you
know I would if I were a betting person
I would probably put money on the both
being gone before too long hmm too long
as it in this year
and actually kind of I've I've got no
idea I mean every prediction I ever make
is generally wrong written but I I I
think I can't imagine that Gavin
Williamson will stay much longer and I I
think given serella bravaman's um a
propensity for enormous errors which he
repeats and claims that they are
accidental when they're clearly very
deliberate I can't see her lasting that
long either I wouldn't be surprised if
they were both gone by the end of the
year Ali tell us about the extra bank
holiday that uh we are going to have to
mark the coronation of Charles III
yes this is on May the 8th uh we know
that the coronation is going to take
place on a Saturday which is I think
what Prince Charles wanted he wanted
minimal fuss he wants to slim down
monarchy he's also very well aware of
the cost involved in this he uh does not
want a complete Fanfare for his
coronation he wants a respectful event
of course it's something that he's been
waiting 70 years for the for the job of
the longest apprenticeship in history so
it should be marked uh properly in a
dignified manner but he also understands
the precious people are under with a
cost of living crisis so I think he
wants something that is fitting but
Rishi sunak I think is doing absolutely
the right thing it is a moment in the
nation's history
um it's the first time in most of our
lifetimes this will have occurred and I
think it's absolutely fitting that we do
have a bank holiday to Market on the
Monday
Christina to the Daily Star their
headline Beware of the Cockroach which
is actually a story about cockroaches
but they seem to have pictured
um
Matt Hancock
yes I mean there's not much evidence of
what the story is actually about beyond
the fact that apparently insects are
endangering the planet but since
absolutely everything's endangered
during the planet at the moment it's
hard to blame one particular species
um but yes I have to say that the
prospect I mean not that I'll watch it
obviously but the prospect of Matt
Hancock not only not only eating
cockroaches or whatever he has to do on
this uh TV show but also claiming he's
doing it as some kind of public service
is so nauseating it doesn't doesn't even
bear thinking about so if I were the
Cockroaches I'd go scuttling away as
soon as possible Christina and Ali thank
you so much for taking us through the
papers we'll see you in the next hour
thank you